so I will just jump right into it I
should warn you all I'm probably going
to be moving pretty quickly so feel free
to jump in with questions I have a
terrible habit of preparing way too many
slides and this topic is really
compelling for me so I really tried to
stuff a lot of things in so broadly
speaking I'm going to talk about a eyes
legal history and some guesses about the
future or considerations about the
future this definition is mostly mine
there isn't really enough law about AI
especially in the u.s. to really make
this a topic where you'd have a textbook
so this is sort of I have picked what
interests me and know that there are
other ways of looking at this topic so
I'm gonna talk just briefly to set the
stage the basics about Launay I then
talk a bit about how AI is making its
way into law and government and make a
few perilous predictions in the sense of
predictions about the future never come
true everybody's always wrong so with
that in mind I first have a couple of
questions for you guys just so I know
who I'm talking to
firstly raise your hand if you're from
the US I just want to get a sense of how
in touch people are with the political
situation okay and regardless of whether
you're from you you are from the US or
not would you say you're reasonably
familiar with the legal and federal
government systems really basic yeah
okay and have you totally different
question because this one I think is
really tends to be a no from this kind
of population have you had jobs or
volunteer opportunities where you have
worked with vulnerable populations right
so you've worked with people who don't
have Amazon Prime subscription zand
haven't necessarily been to college let
alone grad school okay so there that's
where I tend to see that people don't
always have that experience so I'll try
to emphasize that bit of it fair warning
this talk is a bit of a downer I love
technology I don't mean to be an entire
technology I'm not thrilled about the
state of US law as it pertains to
technology
I'm not against the AI but the a the law
in my opinion recently has failed more
than it has succeeded that is a typical
trajectory for US law we are very
different from European and Asian
jurisdictions for example we tend to let
a problem develop often see how far that
problem will go and then we regulate we
very sort of deal with it when it comes
up kind of attitude which is very
different from other jurisdictions with
similar economies while past cases show
success for the u.s. approach right
people are we saying the u.s. approach
to regulation is fantastic best
financial markets in the world this
contract law in the world let's just see
what happens with AI the problem is is
that as you know AI is moving a lot
faster than other technologies right I
mean I sound like a broken drum and we
hear this all the time on ads but it's
true here's a case in point right so in
the bottom is from an Atlantic Monthly
article about the rate of adoption of
technologies the half life for adoption
of these sorts of technologies like cars
like 5 10 15 years look at the use of
deep learning at Google and we see the
half-life is like less than a year right
it's it's going pretty quickly and then
when you think about the spread of
Google itself that also had a really
short half-life relative to a lot of
these physical technologies right now
everything spreads really quickly so
these arguments that well civilian
aviation existed for decades before the
FAA was developed well fine but how many
people had an airplane anyway right I
mean even if a few of them crashed not
to sound heartless it wasn't actually as
big a deal as something going wrong with
an AI system would be that would be
instantaneous problem
just a reminder also over the history of
AI right so another way of pitching this
one way is much sure to half-life to
full adoption right so we should jump in
faster another argument is AI has been
going on for a long time right it has
already had a very long unregulated
history so that's another way of
thinking about it the media is beginning
to be all over this I feel like I cannot
you know read my morning set of
newspapers without finding some gloom
and doom but also some very happy
articles about AI right so this is all
over the news
a few years ago I think the big thing
was discrimination like financial
discrimination this year seems to be the
year of were really concerned about
automated decisions and criminal justice
there's just been an explosion in that
topic so it tends to sort of jump around
in terms of what people are thinking
about and why is this happening right
why are we at a special moment just to
make sure we all agree we've got
big data that's been happening for a
long time we've got deep learning that's
been happening a little less but it's
rapidly getting adopted right Apple just
rolled out core ml so now you're gonna
have neural networks all over your
iPhone Android is have it already for
quite a bit mobile platforms and cloud
intelligence also a change in the
culture right we've got tell all users
now and these platforms tend to
encourage that and reward that behavior
so we had an it had it in us already
then the platform rewards us for telling
all we get discounts we get to share
things with our friends there are all
these rewards for telling all but it
also means we're just giving it away and
not really thinking about how its
regulated or if it's regulated lack of
legal regulation of any kind or guidance
I might be seeming to think about
privacy and of course these topics are
interrelated but this is not a privacy
talk right when people talk about AI
they tend to talk about two main things
not that there aren't others and not
that they aren't connected right they're
not really discrete things so one is
privacy the one I want to focus on more
today is discrimination it's two sides
of the same coin right you're giving
away information and people might
discriminate illegally in morally or
just unfortunately right there are kinds
of discrimination that are not illegal
arguably somewhat immoral but they still
affect people right and they still don't
really achieve what anybody wants so
we're gonna be thinking about
discrimination particularly in the form
of unintended consequences right that's
what I'm most concerned about especially
talking to people who do this for a
living or who do research on this right
you want to be thinking okay I'm a good
person I'm not intending to do anything
but what are we doing maybe accidentally
that could be affecting millions of
people as soon as we roll out production
code also remember there are many forms
of discrimination right so this is the
EEOC definition list right it's not even
necessarily an exhaustive list although
these are the most salient legal
categories so things like gender race
religion also remember there are two
kinds of discrimination and legal
standards so first you can look for
disparate treatment right intent the
boss deliberately scheduled people of a
certain religion at a certain time right
that was intended disparate
pack is usually what you're going to be
looking at usually what the litigation
will be because nobody these days is
like yes I'm discriminating and that's
how it's going right a people don't want
to discriminate and even people who do
know they don't want to get caught right
so everything these days is about
disparate impact no intent is required
that's really good because it's really
hard to prove intent right if you have
to go to a court and say I know what
so-and-so was thinking unless they would
sort of left their diary on the internet
it can be really hard to show that but
disparate impact can even be facially
neutral you just need to show it
adversely affected a protected group and
you usually will use statistics to do
that okay
so what if you're the edge case right I
want you to be thinking about that as
you think about your own work so some
human elements in a I write where where
can this come in all over the place
construction of your data set what data
sources you use what you count as an
event that you're interested in studying
what methodology you're using what
counts as wrong or an outlier right we
almost sometimes say that's an outlier
I'm throwing it out or that's wrong you
are making a decision especially if that
did is about a person that that person
doesn't count very much and that doesn't
mean you're wrong to do it but it means
you want to think very carefully when
you make those decisions how to match
novel situation or to existing patterns
if at all right when you do that when
you save all these situations we don't
have in our data set but we want to deal
with how will we deal with those you're
making a judgment call there as well
setting acceptable levels of false
negatives and false positives right
again you are making a decision that
could in fact have disparate impact on a
group interpreting models or deciding
not to interpret them right deciding oh
this accuracy is really good I'm not
going to go any further I'm not going to
think about how this works that's also a
decision you're making that could have a
disparate impact doesn't mean you're
always wrong to do it but you need to be
aware of possible consequences and
defining edge cases so also I just want
to talk a bit about what we think of as
AI right so Turing said that question of
whether machines think was too
meaningless to deserve discussion Stuart
Russell and Peter Norvig talked about
the concept of a rational agent one that
achieves the best out
or the best expected outcome so that's
the definition I'm taking of right
something that can if performed by a
human be said to require intelligence
and another way of thinking about it is
how many companies these days have lines
of code that directly control humans
right like if you're an uber driver or
you work at five or things like that you
actually your your job might not even be
coming from a human right you just got
assigned to it and think about what that
means and how far we really want to go
especially as far as how that can impact
vulnerable populations okay so I want to
talk a bit about these things and in
particular this case study have
automated welfare benefits from the
1970s to today I'm guessing this is
something none of us have experience
with especially in the 1970s it is an
ongoing issue though administration of
welfare benefits is something that
continues to be automated and this is
where sort of some knowledge about the
u.s. system of government comes in handy
the u.s. system of government is highly
fragmented right we all I mean everyone
here it's indicated some level of
familiarity but I wonder if you
understand just how local it can be so
you probably do if you've come from a
small town if you're someone like me who
grew up in New York City and thinks
everything's professionalized it was a
real surprise when I spent a few years
in rural Pennsylvania and realized that
the people making zoning decisions don't
even know anything about zoning and it
tends to just fall to who got elected
they try to do their best but they don't
know ease even have the expertise to do
things or to think about things
statistically so it turns out a lot of
the government can be said to be being
run by people who don't have a lot of
technical education and yet they are
buying technical products and using them
so as early as the 1970s states were
using automated decision-making for
administering social welfare programs as
you can imagine this was a disaster the
computers crashed and lost data
bugs caused delays in the delivery of
Medicaid benefits and food stamps and
this might not sound that serious but if
you know these sorts of vulnerable
populations if you have worked with them
people who get these sorts of benefits
some portion of them really by the time
their next check is coming they don't
have anything there is no food in the
fridge maybe the electricity has been
turned off winter
is coming but their heating bill hasn't
been paid it can be really worrying to
think that these people would have days
or weeks of delay and getting their
benefits during which they have no
resources to fall back on inaccurate
database information led to over and
under payments so if you got
overpayments you might think okay
nothing bad happened to that person in
fact even the overpayments are bad
because when the government does figure
out that you had overpayments they will
come back to you for that money
but some portion of those people will
have spent that money and have no chance
of getting it back right so even giving
them extra money that they have to repay
is actually a disservice the state and
federal government however remained
undisturbed so especially then there was
sort of a recurrence in the 1990s so in
the 70s some of these systems got put in
they were not so great they mostly
stayed around sort of stable and then in
the 90s again there begins to be this
pressure to save money the 90s is a
period of budget shortfalls of a
government controlled by people who are
particularly interested in cutting back
the welfare state in the u.s. there's
also the falling cost of information
systems emergence of the Internet at
around the same time so the states again
did a new round of automating portions
of public benefit programs these public
benefit programs actually tend to come
from federal money but the state's
administer them and each one does it a
little bit differently and has their own
system and hires their own local vendors
or not so local vendors to implement it
these programs were characterized by
pre-programmed decision logic right so
this these are not machine learning but
they are AI in the sense of do replacing
a case worker right replacing someone
who probably would have had a master's
degree in social work with a set of
control logic if this then that you can
imagine it's hard to write a lot of
if-then it's hard to write a lot of
offends for something that actually
requires a master's degree and is always
under development right these
administrative rules sort of get written
and rewritten constantly the computer
programs did not get updated and what's
more the computer programs were
often missing a lot of the logic in the
original rules but of course there
wasn't anyone all that well qualified to
audit this right because the people who
know the rules don't tend to be
technologically savvy the private
vendors who have been hired to implement
this don't know all the rules they might
have the best of intentions but they
also have a budget they also have time
limitations so they do their best and
probably like many of us have not worked
with vulnerable populations so they
themselves might not understand the full
cost of even getting one of those
if-else statements wrong so this is sort
of what went on in the 1990s and then
there are there are a few things to
think about in terms of when this
happened and when these problems happen
what are the reactions right when
vulnerable people look for help and it's
not always that easy for them to look
for help they might not know the phone
number to call they might not have a
caseworker anymore because this
automated system replaced their
caseworker so what do they do when they
have trouble with the automated system
not entirely obvious there are a few
other things to keep in mind automation
bias the use of automation as a
heuristic replacement for vigilant
information seeking and processing right
we have all seen this I got an answer
from the computer I'm just gonna stick
with it I don't even know if it's right
but I just don't want to think about it
right this is a very natural human
impulse you can also be scary to
challenge the computer right that's
another form of automation biased if I
say the computer is wrong people might
look at me like I'm crazy and perhaps
justly so most of the time we have all
of these edge cases is the problem
another observation for you is AI tends
to get deployed first on vulnerable
vulnerable populations who fall victim
to automation bias so there have been
some articles this year I'm noticing
about how at the lower level right sort
of blue-collar retail jobs more and more
automation is being done in terms of
screening candidates however I'm
guessing most of you if you're software
engineers or data analysts when you got
your last job you went in for a series
of one-on-one interviews maybe your
friend referred you maybe they took you
out to lunch maybe they paid you to move
to New York they treated you like a
person right so there's this interesting
idea that the more you make you know the
more sort of we're going to
do you know touchy-feely but if you
don't make that much now it's all going
to get automated another point somebody
made that I hadn't even thought about is
they are using these automated
algorithms to decide about recidivism or
to judge who is most likely to become a
criminal or commit a crime but nobody
has yet tried to model police
misbehavior even though there must be
tons of data and I mean when I heard
that I just thought my goodness even
when I'm thinking about these topics
that just went right past me the fact
that you can obviously turn the model
around use the exact same data set and
get other information about the more
powerful people in their relationship
okay so some more examples of automated
decision making bloopers as far as
public benefits go so in the 1990s in
Florida relatives of children could not
apply for benefits on behalf of the
children okay I mean we could all take
Ana niece or nephew right you think
about it except to remember poverty
tends to cluster so if you are somebody
who has to take care of your sister or
brother's child
because that person has a drug problem
or is in jail you yourself are also
likely to not have very much money and
to need help so this seems like oh when
I'm programming this seems kind of like
an edge case let's just toss it to the
side but actually this is a lot of
people and this is a lot of children who
live below the poverty line so again
this is actually a disaster even though
it sounds kind of esoteric in New York
battered asylum seekers could not apply
for benefits again when they rolled out
the automated decision making program
they just forgot to put that button in
oh and let me backtrack in Florida it
was even worse because they deployed a
website there was no phone number there
was nowhere to get redress if you
managed to get through your only redress
with you were referred back to the
website so it's it's sort of a cycle a
cycle of disaster more recently right
you think we would learn from this thing
part of the problem with the u.s. system
and I I love the u.s. I love the u.s.
system it has many good things but
because it's fragmented people don't
always learn from one another's mistakes
right so you think the 70s the 90s we
would have learned a lot also we're
always hiring our governments are always
hiring new contractors maybe startups
right who are gonna do this better and
faster we keep making the same mistakes
right so in 2004 two
in Colorado we see the following
patients with breast cancer and cervical
cancer homeless patients are denied
benefits related to Medicaid even though
they are entitled relatives of children
already on Medicaid so we see that
problem with the Florida family members
taking care of other people's kids
resurfacing in Colorado 15 years later
pregnant women in fact 50% of all u.s.
births are covered by public assistance
so when you think about it that means
probably around 50 percent of the births
in Colorado needed these benefits and
were denied them for a period of years
and similarly the Texas system which had
been operating for more than 10 years
failed 4 out of 6 test cases in 2007
when they finally decided to do an audit
another point I want to make where did
these examples come from they were
gleaned from press coverage and Law
Review articles as with all things that
happen in the world at least in the u.s.
we don't tend to have central reporting
repositories right even academics or
regulators when they want to know about
these things they kind of just have to
go out and see where the news coverage
has been maybe check online forums write
see what people are reporting has
happened to them because there is
nowhere to go if you have been the
victim of automation of welfare benefits
to report this this seems a little
unfair right so you might say well we
just live in a decentralized world but
given that these technologies are built
on sort of centralized data repositories
it seems especially unfair that you are
subject to something that has
centralized data but its performance
does not in turn have some sort of
repository so that's something to think
about so I would just say why not better
track such problems so I'm I'm actually
going to skip around a little bit
okay so that was 2000 and beyond right
but actually this problem popped up
again in Utah in 2010 so I want to talk
about a case called kwv Armstrong the
ACLU in Idaho Idaho not Utah litigated
this case what happened was a I believe
in 2010 people with developmental
disabilities suddenly had their benefits
cut 20 to 30% with no explanation you
just open your check at some random
point in the year and all of a sudden
your benefits are 30% smaller than you
expected and again remember these are
people where this might be their sole
source of paying for things right when
lawyer has asked why so they some of
these people were savvy enough they had
lawyers they asked why this had happened
and they were told it was a trade secret
there was then a class-action lawsuit in
Idaho for four thousand Idahoans with
developmental and intellectual
disabilities so 4,000 people
wheelchair-bound may be mental
challenges people who can't take care of
themselves and actually have full-time
assistance suddenly don't have money to
pay for their full time assistance or to
pay for the vehicle that needs to
transport them to their doctor's
appointments what had happened in 2011
the department they claim even though
there were problems earlier changed
their budgeting mile model the weights
assigned to variables changed although
no explanation was given at the time or
even during the litigation as to why
they had changed at no point did the
state say why they had done this or how
they had done this some variables were
dropped entirely including needing
assistance with mobility somehow people
decided that the fact that you need
assistance with mobility should not
impact your budget which is really
surprising when you think that people
with mobility issues especially in a
state as rural as Idaho probably need
transport they need to get into the
shower they need to go up and down
stairs in their home because they didn't
get to choose where they live and maybe
there are stairs there are all sorts of
reasons that's totally relevant
historically around 60% of automatically
calculated budgets had required
Corrections so even before they changed
their process they knew that more than
half the time they were wrong
and in the past they had hired people to
fix those problems they had decided this
would be a way of saving money so this
was challenged the state did not agree
to negotiate with the ACLU originally it
actually went to court that doesn't
always happen right usually if you see
the government and they're dead wrong
they'll say oops we'll fix it and they
fix it they didn't do that here and in
fact what they did is they said no this
is fine and on top of that we're not
releasing the code because it's a trade
secret so we're not telling you how we
got what we got what were the holdings
in the case well the first rule is that
this code couldn't be a trade secret the
holding isn't that no code can be a
trade secret but in this case the
government was not entitled to hold this
as a trade secret also the court found
just by looking at the initial data that
the model was based on corrupt data in
fact with the company that supplied the
model to Idaho had not revealed was that
two-thirds of the data had been removed
prior to model training right so when
you think okay I'm just making a
judgment call about certain data being
an outlier and it's one out of a million
or one out of a thousand no big deal you
would hope that people when they start
removing two-thirds of the data set
especially a data set about vulnerable
people who might not readily fit into
nice category is that you would be a
little concerned when you're removing
far more than half of that data there
was also unexplained Geographic
variation that almost seemed to suggest
and again we can't verify any of this
because the company refused to provide
any information forget their source code
they didn't even want to provide exactly
how they pre-process their data
there was also unexplained variation so
if certain towns were very lucky and
didn't have their budget cut at all
whereas other towns had their budget cut
even more than 30% so this was also
surprising Why should there be
Geographic variation and entitlements
not related to cost of living finally
the court found that the formula was an
unconstitutional violation of the due
process clause because the results had
produced were so arbitrary for such a
large number of people right so almost
everyone who was receiving these
benefits had massive cuts and there was
no reason their situation hadn't changed
to give you an idea of how long these
things take to settle the case was only
decided in 2016
in fact the ultimate settlement is still
awaiting court approval right so the
decision came down at the trial level
the parties are now working out how the
state is going to make victims whole and
what it's going to do in the future to
make sure this doesn't happen again
right so four years of litigation during
which maybe some people didn't get their
full benefits back let's remember that
during litigation depending on what the
court decides you might be stuck at your
new lower level right so even the fact
that you have a case going on does not
ensure swift to justice and especially
for people this is one of the plaintiffs
who are homebound who are in a
wheelchair who have been described some
of them as having functional ages of
eight years old right so these are
people who it might not even be safe to
leave them alone for both physical and
mental reasons right maybe they just
can't keep themselves safe have been
dealing with lowered budgets so this is
all sort of gloom and doom to say if you
are really irresponsible as you develop
models and if you are working with
vulnerable populations horrible things
can happen probably nobody wanted them
to happen but that doesn't really change
things right the ACLU still had to step
in and do four years of litigation okay
so as I predicted I have produced way
more slides and I have time for so I
would love if you guys would take a look
at these on your own I just have a few
closing thoughts before we have
questions okay so I just want to talk
briefly about the near future there's a
lot more interesting litigation going on
there's not much regulation in the US
yet but a couple of interesting things
one there's a decision that just came
down from the Wisconsin Supreme Court
Wisconsin v Loomis somebody tried to
challenge his being rated as a high
recidivism risk in Wisconsin and the
Supreme Court of Wisconsin right the
highest court of Wisconsin basically
said that since whatever data must have
gone into the model was known to this
man that he was perfectly qualified to
defend himself from whatever rating he
it got right so he's basically saying
whatever inputs they put into their
algorithm to decide that you were a high
risk you know those components so even
though you don't know how you use
you are in a position to defend yourself
Lumis then challenged this and tried to
get certiorari from the Supreme Court
but they actually turned him down in
June so he is now serving a sentence
that has been partially he argues
largely determined by an algorithm for
which he doesn't know the source code
and he doesn't know the use of the
inputs so that's one thing that's been
going on there's also a case called
Sandvik versus lynch so though now it's
Sandvik versus session so this happened
before the change of administration
essentially and this is where you all
might even be aware of this right under
the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act it's
actually illegal to provide false
information on a website or to in any
way violate their Terms of Service
what does that mean if you want to look
for discrimination say in a lender
having an automated algorithm or in
tinder matching people if you want to
say what if they're doing something
impermissible technically right now it
is a criminal offense for you to feed
false information to that app or for you
to run many cases scraping the data it's
actually a criminal offense
this hasn't been seriously tested but
the ACLU argues that it is chilling
speech and certainly chilling research
into discrimination so that's another
case to keep your eyes on it is moving
very slowly through the DC courts
political near future right the Obama
administration had put out a few white
papers on the future of AI and big data
raising some concerns but also raising
you know the promising possibilities on
the other hand the Trump administration
Trump campaign sort of on a bring jobs
back to America platform which may or
may not conflict with AI so there are
some questions there although I don't
think we've seen him take much action
either way with regards to big data and
AI local laws so I was really interested
to see that New York City is actually
trying to pass some legislation to
compel agencies when they use AI by
which I mean any automated
decision-making to release the source
code and also to permit people to test
the behavior of those algorithms so
essentially they're saying that Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act we don't want that
to stop research into whether agencies
are using discriminatory software or
even just bad software so they are
trying to enable that of course there
has been
back from industry which is fair right
it's not fair to require people to give
away their IP but local sophisticated
jurisdictions are beginning to look into
solutions on the more outlandish sort of
idea about how we're gonna deal with
this there are also things like basic
income experiments right so there are
some like very far-reaching far-seeing
sorts of things going on in terms of how
are we going to deal with this and then
I've really been excited in the last
year or two I think we are seeing more
technical solutions right so I don't
think we're seeing legal solutions but
we are seeing a lot of researchers and
computer science and statistics looking
into how can we ensure that our models
are fair right and can we write a
general framework to look for
discrimination so this is fair test
Columbia put this out last year it's
very easy to integrate it's written in
Python it works very nicely with pandas
there are also technical solutions for
correcting results so these two paper
this paper just came out on archive this
week talking about how we can remove
gender stereotypes from word embeddings
when we're doing neural networks and
language and then finally there's
practical guidance that goes back quite
a while right so I was also interested
to see that the Association for
Computing Machinery even as far back as
1992 recognized the ability of software
to embed discrimination and put that in
their code of conduct right that this is
something that people should be looking
out for when they craft software so
thank you for coming to my talk and I am
happy to take questions now or after did
I tell you she's someone you want to
know I'm gonna pass the mic down I
awesome talk at the very end you had a
slide about basic income can you talk
more about just what models being used
for that is just determining like which
cohorts the population should receive
vixen for like ubi or like some type of
like stipend so there are there are
different models and there are many
experiments going on in most of the
places I mentioned so for example
there's an experiment going on in Kenya
and that one I think they selected a
whole rural village and everybody is
just getting a certain amount of money
or really every family so they're doing
it by family and everyone sort of
pitches their goal differently so their
goal is to just see
does that help people sort of improve
their lives versus say there's one in
Finland where they're more interested in
seeing does it make people happier and
does it affect their decisions right
because sometimes people will say oh if
you give basic income employments going
to go down people aren't going to be
motivated so the Finland experiment is
more aimed at we're gonna pick some very
wealthy people in a developed country
just some random selection and see if it
changes their behavior which is also an
interesting question there was a one a
few years ago Switzerland ran because
they they recently had that referendum
about whether they should just have
basic income but before that they had
done a study and in that one they had
pitched it they were going to give it to
everyone but they also pitched it as a
way to cut down on the cost of social
benefits administration if we just give
everyone money then we don't need to
worry about social benefits anymore and
we can get rid of that whole apparatus
I'm really skeptical of that rationale
and I think they also found that people
who receive benefits some subsection of
them you wouldn't want to just give them
money and let them run wild with it
because they don't act very responsibly
so yeah there's a whole panoply of these
experiments and different rationales and
very different organizations running
them right so it's anything from the
w-h-o - I think Sam Altman sponsored one
in San Francisco - the Finnish
government thank you for the great talk
I wanted to pick up on I think a line
you said you said yeah of course it's
not fair to ask some industry players to
give away their IT their IP sorry well
and I'm part of the people who question
that very term like IP because so many
different things fall under this and
they're unrelated like patents and
trademarks and copyright and well I I
mean I would question this strongly
because if you know first of all you
know let's talk about what their IP
specifically is and not use IP precisely
because this is like an umbrella term
used abusively and if you know they made
their so-called IP by discriminating
against people and you know that can
very well happen
along the contracting chain because you
know government services have clients
who are these whatever players with some
IT IP interests I mean I don't think we
can be that well Madhab vyas that it's
not fair to me I think to me it's fair
to question their IP if it's based on
discrimination so I tend to be more
sympathetic to your view at times as
well I definitely think we need to look
towards a refinement or segmentation of
what we define as IP even under the
traditional patent system right because
we don't traditionally see sort of
protected IP or trade secret which is
even scarier because then it's not
public rolled out to such large groups
and in a way that can really affect
their lives so I agree we need to define
IP you could also just say look these
government contracts are very lucrative
it's sort of guaranteed large margin
work so if people want it maybe they
just know that they have to be prepared
to disclose their software and there
there are other equitable arguments too
right for example if you are making
predictions about recidivism criminality
or any sort of government function you
probably built your product with
government provided datasets that might
even have been public and certainly
shouldn't be shared with just one
company so there are all sorts of
reasons if we get the system right that
I think this is absolutely possible and
the the city is pushing forward but of
course they don't want to alienate
vendors so they're looking for a
solution that might not be the solution
people would pick but that is one that
all the parties can live with given the
system they're transitioning out of okay
that I'm sorry we've ran out of time but
Eileen we'll be around you have you all
have a break right now and she'll be
free to answer questions here so thank
you so much Eileen